welcome to Sesame Street exhibit at the
National Archives check out all the
history of Big Bird Oscar the Grouch and
Ernie and Bert that's Bert and Ernie um
he says I'm gonna ask you about Bert and
Ernie oh [ __ ] about that man who [ __ ]
up please don't touch the costumes
because they're the originals from the
60s the more your oils from your hand
get on them the costumes will start to
smoke and they disintegrate stay away
from the costumes unbelievable if you
want to hear this SME street music you
got to pay hey dummies have little
credit cards get a little well guess
what you got to pay a little bit they
have to play them Manny that Manny you
think it's a free Museum in Washington
DC a free museum did I uh I want to see
big buddy well we all got to pay for it
yeah pay for a people want to sleep in a
free and by the way when I was growing
up any call my parents Manny and daddy
yeah Reginald and Samantha odd so much
to explore here remember do not touch
the puppets uh kids everyone out there
remember no smoking it's not cool it's
not good for you sometimes it's fun
we're asking you please don't smoke
unless you're at a party with some
friends well your parents are around if
your parents are around
[Music]
and don't say curse words